About 2 months ago
I put some little baby seedings in the ground
for our Winter Garden
and I think it's time for an update
because I'm lowkey shocked at how well she's doing
I started by pulling some weeds and chucking them on the grass
cause they looked a lot like
my husband's problem for later
and we've been enjoying so much of this rocket
but it's officially bolted
which must be why they call it rocket right
I found some helpful friends
popped them back and restocked my baby rocket
which I think my American friends call arugula
and you might not know it just by looking at it
but we've actually been eating from this garden every single day
moment of appreciation for the cutest broccoli I've ever seen in my life
I've never grown broccoli before
but I must admit it's the most exciting thing
I think I've ever done ever
I harvested rocket silverbeet
Cavolo nero kale cos lettuce
spinach and bok choy
before it was time to head inside and process
and I don't know if it's just me
but even when I wear gloves
my hands still get dirty
as a mum of young children who loves to clean and get outside
I wash my hands so many times a day
and I have found some soaps in the past have irritated my skin
especially under my rings
But Protex is full of Omega 3 flaxseed oils
which provides a natural antibacterial protection
while maintaining the moisture within my skin
And I’ve found Protex to be gentle enough for everyday use
by the way my green thumbed mother in law
taught me this trick years ago
if you wanna get rid of a stem
turn the leaf upside down and hack sides on an angle
it'll leave you with nothing but leaves
but some stems I like so take it or leave it
that's our garden haul for today